[Music]
how many times have you found yourself
at work and you get into the same
conflict again and again with that same
person of work or how many weekends have
you spent arguing with your spouse or
your kid at home the conflict might be
different from day to day week to week
but the dynamic is the same this is what
Sigmund Freud originally called the
repetition compulsion and this is the
fact that we all tend to repeat the same
dysfunctional patterns of behavior again
and again and again and again even
though our conscious mind says don't do
that don't do that don't say that don't
say that this is the repetition
compulsion and it's more than just a
habit this is a special feature of how
our mind tends to work initially Sigmund
Freud thought that we human beings we
operate on what he called the pleasure
principle we love pleasure and we like
to move away from pain and then he
started working with a whole bunch of
people whole bunch of people who
actually seem to move from one painful
relationship to another so you find
yourself in one domestic-abuse
relationship you get out of it but then
you move to another you find yourself
loose in a dysfunctional relationship
with your subordinates in one
organization you move to a different
organization but they're dysfunctional
here as well
maybe it's not just everybody else maybe
in part it's it's you this is the
repetition compulsion now how do you
deal with this thing the first thing to
do is to be is to become aware of it you
know what is the typical pattern that
you tend to follow in let me think right
now of a difficult relationship in your
own life it could be in your personal
life that could be in your professional
life how do you deal with conflict in
that relationship how does it start
the other side start by saying some
you know some little subtle comment that
gets under your nerves and then you
decide to walk away for 15 minutes your
face starts to get red you come back 15
minutes later you're such a jerk
don't you respond like that or is it
that one side says something and then
you say something back and you very
quickly confront what's the pattern that
you find yourself typically getting into
note that pattern that's your cycle of
discord and they're typically of some
sort of common thread of trigger
something that tends to commonly trigger
those kinds of conflicts it might be
that in your relationship you always
feel second rung wow they're always
trying to act so superior to me or it
might be that you always feel excluded
and the moment the other side says
anything that even subtly demonstrates
exclusion now you're back in that cycle
of discord so how do you deal with the
repetition compulsion first step is to
become aware of your cycle of discord
who says what who says what next because
the moment you know that pattern you can
decide to break any little node in that
cycle and you break the whole cycle
here's the frustrating part though the
honest-to-goodness frustrating part the
moment you try to break that pattern
it's going to feel extremely
uncomfortable for you because this is
what you know this is what is natural to
who you are in your identity and the
moment you try and change that cycle
you're in a sense threatening a part of
your identity for a good reason
but you're threatening it and every part
of your body is going to want to move
back to the way things were before let
me give you an example let me take the
spousal example husband and wife get
into a conflict the wife experiences
emotions very deeply and needs some time
to boil in those emotions before she can
talk the husband wants to get the thing
over as quickly as possible now you take
those two classic individuals and you
put them together
you have a real problem because the
husband wants to talk to thing out right
away and the wife says no no what space
weather and you have a chase situation
of you know attack avoid situation my
advice and I've worked with couples like
this my advice in that kind of situation
I was in one situation working with the
husband and in that situation the advice
was to the husband you know what when
you start to get into that conflict
situation with your wife don't
immediately try to engage take 10
minutes break tell your wife I'm going
to let's take a 10-minute break and
let's talk about this this gentleman
came back to me two weeks later he said
this stuff works like magic but this was
the hardest thing in the world to do he
said because I was there in the bathroom
you know watching those 10 minutes go by
and every thread in my body every blood
vessel and so on was begging me go talk
go talk feeling so uncomfortable
that's the lure of that repetition
compulsion but he fought it 10 minutes
later hey honey let's talk okay let's
talk and they're in a very different
place it's not easy to fight the
repetition compulsion but it is possible
it takes mapping out what is your cycle
and to how do you try and break this
thing uncomfortably try and break it
over time your habit will change and it
will feel more comfortable
[Music]